can you tell me if it's felt your
experience working on quartet and with
Dustin Hoffman a first-time director and
how your approach to acting was changed
over the years as well the world first
of all the park came kind of out of the
blue and it was Maggie and Tom who both
suggested me for it and Dustin kind of
didn't really know me that well but he
saw a Woody Allen film that I'd done and
he thought you know I might be okay and
he I never met him before I got the part
he just rang me up and he's a great
talker we talked for two hours and at
the end of it he said well I want you to
do it and I said no you sure oh you know
don't be too precipitous but you don't
know me why don't you bring some people
up and ask but I'm like but he's lovely
he's he's full of energy and full of
kindness and I think he's done a
brilliant job an amazing job when you
consider that he's an American and this
is such an English film yeah how's your
experience of acting and your approach
to acting changed over the years
I don't know it has I think probably I
came very late to film not til I was 50
so that was quite latest to be starting
in film but my approach to acting has
always been to try to behave with truth
that's all I can say really and I I'm
not very analytical about it I just get
on and do it and if it feels right I
want it on screen if it feels wrong I'll
perhaps stop and try again it's a great
carrot you've got in the film as one she
has her she's fantastic isn't she what
is it that appeals to you about as I
merge I think the thing I love most of
all about is those she's beginning to
lose her mind you know to dementia she
it's happening joyfully if such a thing
can be true and she's she's trying to
cover it up and she's fighting against
it and she only occasionally has real
serious lapses like she does towards the
end of the film but I think she's she's
a person who always says yes to
everything and I I love that about her
she's a person whose cup is always half
full or even three-quarters
and how much of a new you classical
music as well too cause that's important
in the film is they love it and we all
learnt to sing I mean we all had learned
how to sing the piece and at one point
Dustin wouldn't hurt us and he wanted to
use us but of course although I think
the idea was you know that not that we
did it well but that we did it at all
impressed him so in the end you don't
hear our voices but we had a great time
learning and having the lessons and
feeling oh maybe this is something we do
a bit of
you